the jurogan experience
you uh you recovered from surgery huh
what did you have done dude i've had a
[ __ ] year yeah um so uh just over a year
ago i ruptured my tricep on my left arm
i
was attempting the log press world
record and what is the world record so
the show was to attempt the world record
um i
failed at 485 pounds which would have
been a new american record that's when
my tricep decided to you know crap out
so what did it do like separate from the
bone oh no it like my tendon exploded
so
typically like when a tendon tears it's
kind of like a piece of paper throw a
couple of stitches in it and then you
know anchor it into the bone
the doctor first thing he said when i
woke up was
so when i opened up your arm i literally
had to take a step back and rethink
everything i was going to do because it
was that much worse
but didn't he have an mri to go by yeah
but like so the mri it showed that it
was torn
but he didn't know to like what extent
and when he got in there he realized
that literally he said it looked like a
firecracker had gone off in my tendon
so it took 14 sutures to put my tendon
back together into something he could
even attach to my elbow
and then another four anchors into my
elbow that he had to drill in and what
was the recovery like i mean i still
can't straighten my arm out all the way
oh that's about us and i got like this
really cute dimple now oh wow that's
normal nasty scar
are you gonna put like a tattoo on it
make it like a snake that's what i'm
thinking yeah i mean i think i feel like
a snake is too cliche maybe it's a fuse
that could be it for your forearm and my
bomb ass for him my husband goes you
should make it a sperm i was like oh
it's like we could just not do that
because like you know there's like no
need how many people have [ __ ] sperm
tattooed on their body that might be
like the least tattooed thing ever it
might be yeah i mean i'm gay and i don't
even want a sperm tattoo it's probably a
girl like sad girls
you know
the ones that definitely have daddy
issues oh yeah yeah so the thing
explodes and what is it when it does
explode like what does it look like on
your arm does it pull up so yeah there
was some there was some recoiling going
on and literally like he said there was
just like tendon fragments like strewn
about fragments yeah literally like a
bomb yeah is that just because the
weight of the log yeah i mean when
you're trying to press 485 pounds
overhead and your body says [ __ ] no it
just goes what do you weigh about 240
280 280. yeah so that's
yeah that's 200 pounds over my body
weight yeah yeah that's a lot of weight
yeah so the rehab is going well for that
um and then like is this you doing it oh
yeah this is when it blows out no so
this is this is when i actually broke
the record so i had already had the
american record at this point
um
and then got the chance so this was like
all coved times so we did like virtual
record breakers so is the judge such an
attention horde uh
he was in lithuania for this oh okay
kind of looks like a white supremacist
there though yeah it's gone siege
highland
so yeah that was 475 so much weight now
when they do the logs like did they put
weight inside the log oh and the ends of
the lock yeah yeah so the log itself
weighs like i think that weighed like
160 pounds or so and then we had to add
25s and stuff to the end of it
to get it to the contest there's
something very primal about lifting a
[ __ ] log too right i mean that's the
sport of strong man right like we lift
stones and logs and like carry [ __ ] on
our back like
that's just what the sport is yeah and
so the elbow just
totally shut the bed and how long did it
take before you could lift again
so i was like back in the gym within
like two weeks doing lower body stuff
but the biggest the hardest part was
like getting range of motion back like
trying to flex my elbow again because
when they did the surgery my arm was
bent at 90 degrees so that was a pretty
comfortable position but getting it to
straighten or getting it to bend all the
way was
horrible do they anticipate you'll ever
get full range of motion
it's been a year so so here's the weird
thing nobody can figure this out
if i'm not if i'm just here try to raise
my arm that's as much as i get
but if i'm pressing like if i'm bench
pressing or overhead pressing i can get
to full extension press this cup well i
think it might be too light
[Laughter]
i can't pretend
this is where i get hurt oh this is
where it blows out yeah you'll see that
you've got the same [ __ ] hitler yeah
same dude and there it goes oh jesus
christ oh
yeah
and like you know i'm i'm a certified
athletic trainer like have a master's
degree in sports medicine so like i
legit knew right away what had happened
and my husband comes over to me he's
like what's wrong i was like i just tore
my tricep he's like no you didn't i was
like nah i totally did
oh but you didn't think it was as bad as
it was
i mean i knew it was torn but like i
didn't
yeah i didn't think it was exploding to
that level now what kind of therapy do
you do for something like that once they
reattach it what's the rehabilitation
like um so i mean i i did a lot of
everything a lot of manual therapy
because like i produce a lot of scar
tissue um like even now like my
olecranon like the elbow bone doesn't
feel like
my right one so when you say you produce
just my body it naturally produces a lot
of scar tissue so
that was something we battled actually
because i was producing too much scar
tissue too early in the rehab process
that was actually hindering the range of
motion gains that i was supposed to be
getting
so a lot of like graston um cupping
i was
i did like dry needling and acupuncture
and
one of the one of the first times i went
the therapist couldn't get the needle
through the scar tissue because it was
too thick
and the best the way i describe it to
people is like even with with me like
feeling the needles go in it felt like
pushing a needle through like rubber
that's how it felt for me too like i
felt the stickiness of it do you think
that's just because you trained so much
so your body's just so used to
recovering quickly i think so you must
be have you talked to other guys that
are strong men do they have like similar
situations yeah a lot of us like have
had like the scar tissue stuff that goes
on and then like i actually bent a few
of the acupuncture needles like when
they were trying to do them
like she pulled them out and was like it
was curved i was like oh that's at least
it didn't break off watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify